[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's Dwayne Wade his wife Gabrielle
Union and baby Kavya cheering on Ziya as
she shines on stage the proud family
watched as the 12 year old who recently
came out as transgender saying her heart
out during the school performance
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
her dad took to Instagram to share this
special moment captioning the video
quote joy a filling of great pleasure
and happiness
that's what watching Zayas sing and
dance last night felt life for our
family the retired NBA player also
posted this photo of Ziya smiling with
roses in hand simply captioning it quote
enough said adding a heart eye emoji
making it clear that in the midst of all
the negativity Ziya has faced online
since stepping into her truth aldwayne
is concerned about is her happiness
last month the father of four opened up
to Ellen DeGeneres about the moment SIA
who was born Zion shared that she wanted
to be referred to with female pronouns
twelve year old came home and first died
and everybody I don't know if everyone
knows originally named Zion Zion born as
a boy came home and said hey so I want
to talk to you guys you know I think
going for it I'm ready to live my truth
and I want to be a reference that she
and her I would love for you guys to
call me Ziya and so internally now is
our job to one go out and get
information to reach out to every
relationship that we have
soon after the supportive parent shared
this video of Ziya speaking her truth
what's the point of being on this earth
if you're gonna try to be someone you're
not
it's like you're not even living
so just like the dumbest concept to me
Gabrielle posted the video to Twitter
captioning it quote meet saya
she's compassionate loving whip-smart
and we are so proud of her it's okay to
listen love and respect your children
exactly as they are
love and light good people it's last
month ET spoke with Dwane about how
Zayas journey has helped him grow as a
person you are very vulnerable an open
book in a lot of ways you spoke so
lovingly and eloquently about your
daughter's aya and your family's journey
on Ellen the other day why was it
important for you to put that message
out now about your family's journey well
we're not the only family you know that
that deals with all the things that
we've spoken about we're not the only
family that had to deal with surrogacy
to bring a daughter into the world we're
not the only family that's had to deal
with gender expression gender identity
sexuality with their child so you know
we're just you know we understand the
position that we've been put in
especially in our community and even
though it's not always a popular thing
to speak out on them on issues that
people are comfortable with or not as
educated on but this this is the
platform that God gave me and my family
so we use it
Gabrielle have both talked a lot about
how you reached out to a lot of people
to get information and just educate
yourselves I'll ask you the same thing
what have you learned about yourself
through this process
well me for me is always about being
able to adapt and be able to learn and
always being able to grow you know I
think coming from the inner city of
Chicago early on I was a clue I was kind
of closed-minded on a lot of things
you know and I've been with my wife
traveling the world meeting people going
different places I've learned to open
keeping my mind open keep my eyes open
keep my heart open and keep my thoughts
open and that's what I've been trying to
do as I'm growing it to the man that
I've always been to become
[Music]